and you know I want anyone approaches me
and says I want to be a director III I
always tell them then you should just be
a director and and don't say I'm going
to be because you can direct good or bad
but you can direct from your iPhone from
your cell phone with your sisters cousin
video camera with a webcam with right
now except in the most abject
circumstances most people can get a hold
of an image audio-visual generating
machine and they can be directing and
then realize that they are already
directing directing should doesn't mean
anymore and shouldn't mean anymore
directing feature films I think as I
said with series like Breaking Bad
I was not only amazed at the way it was
written but the way it was staged on
camera it was a really well directed
series and and video games also can do
that and I think that so as long as you
have you have minimal access to any
media you should be a director if you
feel like you are you want to and the
advice I feel is that it's always better
to to answer through your work the
things you don't like in a media in a
piece of media if you dislike the movies
that are being made make your own show
the world what you want to do what you
think this medium should be and and I
find that much more creative than simply
putting it down and complaining about it
is a more active fascinating role to
take so the advice is if you want to
direct by rank and even easier if you
want to write write you know I think
that writing is the only one of the only
things that can be done with very little
resources and even if you died and you
were unpublished you still have a chance
you know if it's truly you cannot do
that with directing you need other
people you need a little bit of help you
need at least an actor in front of the
you know but but I think this are what I
say is gone do it and and you know when
they say oh I would like you to to do
this for me or and I produce a lot of
first-time filmmakers but I don't
produce all first-time filmmakers that
approach me and I say look if I say no
and you give up I'm sorry to tell you
what is the wrong job for you because
you live with rejection for decades
sometimes as a director and you end up
making the movie you want to make so if
I say no that doesn't mean I'm right or
I'm wrong you just say fuck him I'll
show him later you know I'm going to
make it and that fat bastard is going to
have to say I was so wrong and hit
himself in the head because he didn't do
it and I think that that's the thing to
do is like show us
don't tell us you know do the things and
if you do them wrong but you do them in
your own terms that's how I define
success failing in your own terms